(upbeat music)
- Hi, friends, it's Inga.
I recently heard about this
place called The Dream Machine.
It calls itself a new immersive experience
that brings the most
magical dreams to life.
We're supposed to walk through 10 rooms
that are inspired by our sleep cycle.
I have absolutely no idea what that means,
but we're just gonna go to the location,
check it out, and have some fun.
- I'm Paige Solomon.
I'm the co-founder and creative
director of Dream Machine.
Dream Machine was inspired by sleep dreams
and the whimsical nature of dreaming.
We wanted to create a space
that was a respite from reality.
You'll find yourself walking
through a cloud land on Cloud 9
and that is the first
point in which each guest
will really be falling asleep.
- There's a lot of clouds in here.
Look at all these lights.
This looks like what it
would be if I was dreaming.
We tend to forget about our dreams,
so this is kind of like reliving it.
It's a very surreal feeling.
You don't really see anything like this
outside of this space.
I do actually feel a little bit sleepy,
which I think is kind of the point.
I think the feeling it
gives you is very much like
how I remember feeling from a dream.
I'm feeling great, I have
my head in the clouds.
Literally.
- [Paige] Soon as you're asleep,
you enter a fog bubble machine,
and that's really your first transition
into this dream world.
- Holy moly, this is blowin' my mind.
I thought they were bubbles,
but they dissolve into smoke.
You know how in dreams things
don't really make sense?
This is like that.
Bubbles that turn into smoke?
That's so bizarre.
I feel like a wish.
(blowing)
A little bit too wet here.
This is the part where I think
I wet my bed in my dream.
- [Paige] From there, you walk
into a black and white room
because some people only
dream in black and white.
- That's scary looking.
I've never dreamed in black and white,
but if I did, this would
probably be a nightmare for me.
(laughing)
- [Paige] And then the
black and white room
starts to transition black and white tiles
into a neon-lit laundromat.
- I'm making cotton candy
out of a washing machine.
Better than any cotton
candy I've ever tasted
out of a washing machine.
- [Paige] In the laundromat
you can crawl through dryers
into an infinity room.
- Check this out.
There's a lot of little lights in here.
I feel like I'm in a mini galaxy,
really serene, quiet.
What?
Well, that was trippy.
I just came out of a washing machine.
Movin' on.
- [Paige] From there you'll
find yourself diving underwater
into a ball pit swimming pool
that looks like you're at the
bottom of a swimming pool.
- Steps to the pool.
I am in a sea of plastic balls.
I love the watery wavy
patterns on the ceiling.
We're just chillin' underwater.
I never wanna get out now.
- [Paige] From there, that transition
is a 40 foot long rainbow hall.
- We are in the rainbow room.
You can see the colors changing.
It is trippy.
I feel like Alice in Alice in Wonderland.
Going down the rabbit hole now.
Will I find a pot of gold
at the end of the rainbow?
I wonder.
- [Paige] You then find yourself
immersed in our print garden,
a room filled with 70 plants
with all different prints, patterns.
- I feel like I'm at a fancy rainforest.
These plants have little shapes on it.
A polka dot leaf, there's striped leaves
and then there's mac and cheese leaves.
It can be whatever you
want, it's your dream.
- [Paige] And then it's time to wake up.
You'll find yourself immersed in 15 feet
of metallic streamers.
- We're goin' in.
Is this ever going to end?
I feel like I've been here for forever,
(gasps) and we're out.
It was all a dream.
Ta-da!
I feel like I'm waking up.
Now that we've finished the entire tour,
I finally know what the dream machine is.
It was actually pretty cool.
There were so many room
that I honestly felt
like I was in my dream.
So, after all that, back to reality it is.
Actually, never mind.
Bye, guys.
(relaxing music)